[Music]
a
my tv money
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um yeah that's a good slurp it's a slurp
slurping up monday it was dangerous
which generally one wants to avoid
because monday is uh filled with
xenoestrogens and
toxins disgusting what the science is
out if you drink
bpa plast from bpa plastic bottles you
might it might mimic estrogen in the
body
or if you don't eat organic food right
some of the pesticides might mimic
estrogen in the body it's
but when injected directly into a
six-year-old's butt however
we're a little murky in the science oh
thanks dr levine
hey gerald is here how are you i'm well
how are you never well
quarter black garrett accepted amongst
no communities yep just don't forget it
and brian callan is here right yes
brimming with testosterone i did my
goblet squats did you get goblet squats
yeah i go deep
well that's usually for women who don't
know how to squat really is a training
method but
you're going to be performing yes i'm
sorry i was i was admiring how tight my
sweater was it's very tight i apologize
for my tight sweater a trunk um where am
i
oh yeah huntsville alabama ladies and
gentlemen home to nasa
march 25 26 27 only if you like to laugh
hard
yeah big and hungry podcast dropped
today look at that
wow you're not doing so many things
there's a social club on patreon it
keeps going
we have a lot to talk about today too
george floyd uh we have a few questions
for you
hey have any of you tried fentanyl how
does it compare to heroin
um i'm asking for a friend comment below
and
uh we're talking about i don't know if
you can store it artie lange
broke his septum snorting heroin yeah
heroin is different fentanyl it's all
pesky i think it comes in a liquid form
does it really i don't know i don't know
someone said to our p.o box
unmarked uh we'll be talking about that
we'll be talking about the cancel
culture apparently it's going after
governor cuomo
sarah silverman apparently anti-cancer
culture
and uh so is bill maher now talking
about the dangers of china
it's almost like someone was talking
about this before
uh as well as what else are we talking
we have a lot but mainly george floyd
and the riots
but first last night at the grammys
because we have to address this
little baby baby uh
simulated a black lives matter riot
anyway here's a clip from what happened
last night
[Music]
it's been a hell of a year hell for over
400 years
my people it's time we stand it's time
we demand the freedom that this land
promises
president biden we demand justice
first off i don't know what justice
you're demanding and secondly i'm pretty
sure biden doesn't understand you
yeah what the guy screwed up in his
speech he screwed up the first
word i didn't want to talk about the
speech because it was thursday his first
he was meant to say tonight he goes
to light did he know and it was one of
those things
where you could see on his face you know
someone who would be smart enough would
say like
to light oh i'll take it from the top
but instead you could see on his face he
immediately wanted to check out and not
finish the speech
to light you know the you know the thing
americans and he still had to do it it
was like the boom goes the dynamite kid
uh hey by the way you saw that i don't
know if you noticed this bring up the
side by side
they were simulating bombing of wendy's
which by the way they blamed on white
people with the rayshard brooks
shooting and the funny thing they they
showed that clip right before them when
we cut away
they showed a guy being put down on the
the pavement and then just getting up
and running away and then getting shot
that's not what happened exactly that's
exactly what happened no he body slammed
two cops and stole their weapon and ran
away and pointed it at them it seems
they missed a few
big races if you wake somebody up from a
nap
i'm so grouchy you get super grouchy
not a morning i'm gonna body slam i will
body slam you
although that's impressive too because
when i wake up from a nap i gotta i need
my tea i can't
just go right into a body slam no you
gotta have a little tet leaves it's how
you hurt your back
perk yourself up that's true little
caffeine fenin it's a nootropic
um speaking of which this is we'll just
hit this really quickly some of the most
notable uh remarks here from biden's
speech before we get to sarah silverman
and george floyd but you should watch
the whole thing for yourself
yeah um and when you watch it you'll
understand why he has had
zero press conferences um but
there's also something at play more
subversive that really
should disturb us all as americans
america is coming back
the development manufacturing
distribution of vaccines and record time
is a true miracle of science if we do
our policy
if we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout and a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together oh thank you
uncle joe thank you we'll be allowed
small groups
hey let everyone know in the hey control
room back there control room
i don't know if you guys heard that
small groups okay
space house it's not safe small groups
no i don't like he's saying this
are americans watching this going hmm
small groups what we've never not we've
never had anything other than large
groups right this is the only show that
i know of
that never broadcast from anywhere else
ne we didn't even stop doing
team jiu jitsu i cannot believe that
americans out there going well
oh wait for biden's word to see if we
can have a cookout yeah
are you out of your tree sir by the way
do you do remember what that holiday's
about it's about throwing off an
oppressive
government you know so i think there's a
correlation here
someone needs to get in a gyro plane on
the white house lawn and roman candle
into the window because no one gets hurt
but a message gets sent about the
message
[Laughter]
no one else had roman candle flights as
a kid no you know i immediately aimed it
at my brother's face
i got scared for a second yeah um people
get hurt
stephen people get funny uh
all right before no by the way you can
follow me on instagram louder with
crowders where you can follow me have a
lot of stuff there that you don't really
get here
uh since i've been per not permanently
i've been banned from twitter for a week
yeah
it's not not permanent yeah no
explanation no explanation whatsoever
is it permanent like every time you lose
it's not permanent it's for another week
who told you that
i think it's another four days can you
find that out yeah it says oh
is this like joe's crab check like free
crab tomorrow like oh we'll let you back
tomorrow but tomorrow actually never
comes for you with twitter is that
you have a sad history with joe's crab
check that we'll have to examine
something it's on the side of the
buildings right
that you get free crap tomorrow yes it
literally says that
i i have no idea i don't i don't go to
crab shack or
long john silver's i'm generally turned
off because i used to go as a kid like
to mcdonald's and they give me a crappy
sunday i'd say hey
make mine look like the picture but if i
were at long john silver's or crab check
i'd say hey
make mine look like the picture oh it's
a chewed up wrestler's ear you know what
try and make it better
it looks like it looks like cauliflower
here uh by the way the
show is every morning weekday morning 10
a.m eastern that's the best way to uh
that's the best way to tune in so you
don't have to be beholden to
notifications brian
is here today dave landau tomorrow
tomorrow is one year anniversary to
celebrate
15 days to flatten the curve we'll be
going through all the predictions what
came true and then dave landa will be
filling hosting
wednesday thursday i go to have my heart
all checked out at the mayo clinic so i
will not be here i apologize
um you can comment heart i do big
sweetheart i got a big
heart right that is compressed by my
stupid chest
steven was showing me stephen was
showing me a special arm bar yesterday
and he mounted me he's got a lot of
power and his crotch was very hot i just
i said
what listen listen i know twins weird i
started i have twins on the way
doesn't happen by accident so uh also uh
we'll be talking
for those who are not mug club members
we will be getting joe lewis here i
don't want to say his name because he's
asleep
uh we'll try and get him in studio to do
his impression of
a fire engine because every time a fire
engine goes by
he does this
[Music]
every time that's the old wolf
there it is
[Music]
yeah it's pretty good yeah he's pretty
good impressions yeah it's a borderline
purr look at that
but he's never done it when i've done it
on my phone the sound so we're going to
try and use the surround sound of the
studio to see if we can get him to do it
here
um all right anyway so you let me know i
don't know what i'm looking forward to
they do that because they figured out
why wolves do it
they mark their territory and they're
telling other wolves that this is our
area
do you think he's like you think this is
like a throw down like he's hearing them
say this is mario he's like no uh yeah
he's gone dude i'm over here you guys go
over there that's not what disney told
me
disney told me that it was about love
and they don't they don't show you with
the wolf
tearing apart its baby wolf who couldn't
make it to the pack
because that would be a mighty different
disney film how are you going to spell
sex out in the clouds
it's difficult you sick pedophiles fakes
effort
disney is i don't mean some secret
pedophile ring i mean an open
ring that's hyperly sexualizing children
i know because i saw a little mermaid
when i was a kid and when i saw those
clam
the clamshell brassiere i just i just
got very comfortable
[Laughter]
uh this is my question for you today how
did our country get to the point where
you can work your entire life
you can provide for your family uh
barely but a drug addicted violent felon
george floyd jesus christ to someone of
course
uh gets his family 27 million dollars
wow from refusing to comply with the
police and overdosing on uh
chinese fentanyl tell me how you if tell
me before you see what we're talking
about no justice no
peace i don't i don't know what that
means like you want a piece of the break
me off a piece of that fentanyl
i don't know if that's i don't
understand like at this point we're
talking about justice you guys are
struck
27 million dollars we'll get to the
toxicology report in a little bit
that's the story i really want to talk
about today uh but first
this is something that obviously is near
and dear to our hearts brian uh brian
myself gerald not so much but you know
what you're welcome to talk
thank you um this last week sarah
silverman
for people who don't remember sarah
silverman made her entire living made
her bones her career
through shock comedy and then decided to
slam the door
shut behind her pull up the ladder and
tell everyone else that they shouldn't
be offensive that they shouldn't be
cutting edge that we need to be careful
about what we say
but now she is saying that she's tired
of being a democrat because of the
absolutism that she's
she's basically been their enforcer in
chief in hollywood so here's her making
the comments
about uh her disillusion with the
democrats it's the
absolutist ness of the party
i am in that is such a turn off to me
it's so [ __ ] elitist you know for
something called progressive
it allows for zero progress i know right
all or nothing
no we're steps toward all or [ __ ]
nothing
again righteousness porn i think i don't
want to be associated with
any party anymore it just
it comes with too much baggage so do
your new
shows that are not like this isn't this
isn't comedy anymore it's a one-woman
show oh what does that mean i'm going to
berate you and get an award yeah
but at least i mean sarah like i know
sarah and i actually really like her and
i think she's a hell of a comic i really
do she was
yeah i don't know what happened maybe
she's not doing that that stuff anymore
i know she got
i think kicked out of the ted thing or
she got
stopped when she was doing a ted talk
because she was making fun of somebody
who was
who had down syndrome yeah but um
i at least at least she's speaking about
it but the one thing i noticed is that
the the path to redemption is to come
back to the progressive party
right so so it's it's it's like that's
the only thing i'd say is that
look we gotta we gotta give him a path
to come back but that means back
toward us right back that doesn't mean
you that's what unity it means there's
no point you have zero point of view
that's valid if you
are on the right hey hey hey hey hey i'm
gonna be real with y'all
didn't y'all hear that biden's a party
of unity okay well what does that mean
come over here or i'll molotov cocktail
y'all oh
well well it doesn't sound like it
doesn't sound well she doesn't even
apologize for her
role in making it what it is i think
that's the the irony is like i have made
this something that i don't like and i
want to leave the party
the democratic party is saying yeah
she's like they're so elitist oh i
wonder who has been talking about
elitism you've called them nazis and
populist races people
talking about elitists the swamp those
who no longer represent no
no longer uh represent a government for
the people by the people right this is
something we've been talking about for a
long time but why has it gotten
so absolutist hmm let's go to the tail
of the tape
miss silverman anyone should say express
themselves as they should
see fit and if there are consequences
that's part of it
nick cannon brought it like you going
after them on twitter saying anything
that could be
perceived as homophobic yeah yeah i'm
done with that
yeah i think i can find other ways to be
funny yeah
definitely i mean i used to say gay all
the time well that's so gay
we're from boston we go that's all you
say in boston i have gay friends i just
say
gay and then i heard myself and i
realized i was like the guy who said
what i say colored i have colored i say
colors
like i just finished jews don't count by
david bedeal
he is really insightful about the
conceit of
jews are rich and how racist that is
i look like the beautiful queen latifah
well our president threw another party
for himself another
rally full of laughs and cheering all at
the expense of a woman who
shared her story of sexual assault
senators
please believe me when i say this is no
longer a job interview this is a line in
the sand
and you have to pick a side and the side
is no longer republican or democrat
your vote is a statement ironically with
governor cuomo it's a face print in the
sin get down there you like it
i just it's okay is it really well what
about cuomo what about tara reed and joe
biden the inconsistency
knows no bounds and we know this me
brian we know about cancel culture we
know about the the
all the fake me too that happens believe
all women now it's well
you know biden had to answer said let's
let the investigation run its course oh
wait hold on a second so
either we have to go back to due process
which is what we've always advocated
and throw out all of the believe all
women with no evidence
or you find yourself in a tough spot
this is the issue right now it's like
look
i understand and you want to be gracious
but it's got to sting a little bit
because you made sure that people like
us
weren't able to speak and by people like
us i mean half the country
who elect presidents not former vice
presidents also
uh now you have andrew cuomo when the
left is using the word cancel culture
now
unironically you know that it was a
political tool because now they're
coming for them
the mob with torch and pitchfork the
revolution eats its young
the revolution it's a snake eating its
own tail well i don't think it's right
wouldn't put cuomo young the revolution
eats its
pe jerry who if they were the victim of
their own nursing home policies would be
assuming room temperature
but it's pretty hard to put on a bumper
sticker uh here is cuomo right now
here's cuomo he would die all right
here's a clip of cuomo
people know the difference between
playing
politics bowing to cancel
culture and the truth
let the review proceed i'm not going to
resign
well it almost seems like we've heard
this before
but you were the ones saying cancel
culture's not a thing these same people
would say you know what right now
look at the right talking about dr seuss
cancel these are silly issues look
look the banning of books is a big deal
and you can say well the company chose
to do it right with dr seuss
the reason they chose to do it is
because you guys put legal pressure and
you boycott
everybody into your dogmatic secular
religion
that to me is more important than a
stimulus because
what's another few trillion dollars at
this point i'm against it but once you
start removing
language banning books like on amazon
now and they are
you can no longer have books where
people who transitioned yes
are regretting it which is irreparable
damage to that book
which was which was banned remember if
if amazon starts
banning books publishers are going to
say to authors
they're going to say i can you can't
write that book because i can't sell
that book
no publisher is going to take put money
into a book that can't be sold
on amazon right so it is de facto not
only not only
burning books not only censoring books
but you're going to stop people from
there's no incentive to write a book if
i can't get it out there right and what
it's going to do by the way
and is create a parallel economy
i think all of a sudden i think the
reason i like the marketplace is that
now there's now there's probably room
for somebody all right don't do your ben
shapiro advocating bitcoin well listen
when you think of cryptocurrency and
then dark web well actually i invested
in quite a bit
and uh well jesus armored while he but
that's back well with cancel culture the
thing about uh
cuomo the irony is he he killed by his
policies he killed hundreds if not
thousands of people and that's not why
they're coming after him i want him to
be canceled for killing grandparents
at the very the most that we know right
now is inappropriate conduct towards
women that was unwanted right that's all
we know we don't know ray
i don't wanna i don't wanna do the whole
people who are alleging he's a rapist
right right it's cuomo i will say you
know what i don't think he deserves to
uh be to be forced to resign for the
accusations
right i really don't but killing people
killing people that's something
we should focus that's where i would for
me that's my
interns face print in the sand is
killing people
once we've gone past that but you're
talking about proportion now that's
crazy
you know it's it when when they were
talking about the cuomo i read some of
the allegations like he touched a
woman's back inappropriately and said
and asked personal questions and that
person i've read a couple of articles
that
they're calling that person a survivor i
think that's a little bit insulting
women that have really gone through
terrible things or just people who
survived really life-threatening
situational situations it's just
there's just no proportion man how are
you going to make sense of just some guy
coming i mean i just can't it's survivor
it's like tell us your tale of of of
surviving i mean you put me in a lower
bar
in 2014
i was motorboated
i asked for it but i just after when i
look he wasn't very good he didn't have
magic lips it's just like honestly
you've got to tell me this is comparable
to
and my wife we were telling this
yesterday with my wife she made a great
point she goes rape
is horrible she goes but when you're
reading a story he threw on the ground
he forcefully raped her he said
that man should be put to death or
buried beneath the train tracks
she said but these women who didn't do
anything back then this is what my wife
said
are weak women she said if a man put his
hand on my back and asked me an
inappropriate
question right then and there i would
yell at him or say why are you putting
your hand on my back she got in trouble
because she was in morocco
when she was doing the semester abroad
oh yeah and uh this muslim
gentleman in morocco grabbed her
buttocks and she turned around and
screamed at him
and said don't you ever do that and her
actually i guess tour guide whatever and
her mom when she told her she said
don't do that morocco you cannot do that
in an islamic country
we will never see you again just get
away but my wife that's her instinct she
goes if someone is actually sexually
harassing you meaning it's not violence
it's not overpowering
do something then again just one woman's
opinion hit the notification bell
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot plus i'd pin them with
my crotch so notifications are the only
ones listen i can't help
asserting my sexual prowess oh my god um
and something else while we're talking
about canceled culture i feel like i'm
in bizarro world like i've stepped
through some cosmic bunny hole
because now we have sarah silverman
saying i can't believe you know it's so
absolutist and cuomo going i'm not going
to bow to cancel culture
your culture your culture more so than
even your fake italian culture and your
nipple barbells is cancel culture it's
your hair's all day
and now you have bill maher sounding the
alarm
about about actual this is not a joke
now
about china china here you go china
yeah here you go well we're the silly
people now
do you know who doesn't care that
there's a stereotype of a chinese man in
a dr seuss book
china half the country is having a
never-ending woke competition deciding
whether mr potato head has a
and the other half believes we have to
stop the lizard people because they're
eating babies
we are a that's a false equivocation was
changed because of pressure
just to get like two people through
environmental review there's a
progressive trend now to sacrifice merit
for equity colleges are chucking the
s.a.t and a.c.t tests and in new york
mayor de blasio
announced merit would no longer decide
who gets into the schools for advanced
learners
but rather a lottery system you think
china's doing that
letting political correctness get in the
way of nurturing their best and
brightest
those are real and so is china and they
are eating our lunch
okay a couple of things really quickly
here you see this you see this with
sarah silverman let me let me explain
see sarah silverman cuomo cancel culture
and now him talking about not using the
sats lowering standards okay so now we
have three very clear examples
all right has there been a single
republican
who's pushed for anything other than
merit-based education
never has there been a single republican
who has pushed for hate speech
laws or pushed for more censorship on
big debt there might be a couple there i
don't know exactly
very very few how many republicans have
been out there trying to get people
banned for referring to something as gay
or colored which by the way you can say
people of color can't say colored people
i go with colored people just because i
only have so much time in the day
so the issue here is again he's talking
about china if only there was a pr if
only there had been a president who bill
maher had mocked mercilessly
for years sounding the alarm on china
and by the way
you said he was racist and you said that
there was a rising epidemic of
anti-asian hate crimes by white
supremacists which we just talked about
last week 85 percent
of all violent crimes in the bay area
san francisco are committed by blacks
against asians so i tell you what if
this is a byproduct of white supremacy
that is some powerful
third removed racism right we the white
supremacists are so effective they've
gotten black people to do their bidding
against asians or maybe
maybe there's some animosity against
asians because of people like you've
talked about in the new york legislature
because of people for example who said
asians have to score higher
on sats and they're turning them away in
record numbers
from universities like brown and
stanford and lowering the standards for
black people
and so black americans go yeah why does
he have what i got and it creates
animosity against chinese
people who are one generation removed
from or two generations removed from
their grandparents being in internment
camps
and they are disproportionately wealthy
because of their work ethic
and having intact families and you've
told black americans because you see
them through the prism of lasix
race exclusively that the problem is
well everyone hates black people but
everyone loves the asian well they see
them through the prison of being victims
they lump all black people in as a
victim and that's insulting to black
people
right you know and though it's it's
they're often the perp
well and you know you see that wait a
minute okay
that's not what i'm saying at the end of
the day stephen's not giving guys like
bill maher
and people like sarah silverman on the
left are way back it's true
i mean stop putting up walls stephen
they're not building walls they're just
themselves away no i think we need one
sorry
sorry i don't want them in sorry guys
you can't trust it
hey they're being converted i don't
think they're being converted
what they're saying is we need to be
less absolutist so that brian cowan
will check his privilege make sure that
he allows himself to be white-shamed
use our elect use our cultural lexicon
and be a good little surf that's what
they're saying but i'm half italian and
i'm sicilian and my family were peasants
they have short fingers made
for working you know the field yeah it's
not nothing and the moors
you probably you've got some yeah i did
my genome i'm not i'm not
you know viking like yourself i'm not
advised too
oh chest and ass the common thread here
is that the person
the person that they hated and they were
blinded by is now gone
and now reality can kind of creep its
way back in just a little bit and it's
like guys
you hated him so much that every one of
you have done things
against what you're saying right now
like you have actually created the
situation you hate
only because you hated donald trump and
we told you that
you were doing it the left has been
systematically
enabling and empowering china just to
try and spite donald trump and i'm not
even just talking about the you know the
biden family members smoking crack with
chinese prostitutes or eric swalwell
banging mingming
which by the way how was that guy on an
intelligence fang
how was that guy on an intelligence
committee when he was banging chinese
spies
well she was that to be fair she was
very odd i'm sure she was okay
she spoke fluent english guys
and she thought he was powerful there's
only one man knew she was a spy my point
is i don't want to rely on that man
for anything i wouldn't let him watch my
kids let alone be on an intelligence
committee so let's talk about what the
left has done to enable china
because bill maher leaves that part out
right what do we have we have tpp
the only person who opposed it was uh
was uh donald trump uh nato doesn't see
china as a threat you look at the
policies with the u.n you look at donald
trump
you look at donald trump with the paris
accord saying china's building record
they're not gonna
they're not gonna respect this isn't
fair you look at uh
disney of course bowing to china you
look at the nba's billion-dollar
relationship with china where they
banned people who are protesting for the
independent for the liberty of
the hong kong people their right to
peaceably assemble
not to mention the who the world health
organization who dr
fauci said are the most reputable source
for available data regarding covid19
they should be trusted
donald trump said we're not going to be
funding who at all
we won't be involved that was changed
with joe biden this is the same
if you care about human rights no
justice no peace keep in mind
this is the same world health
organization right
who don't even acknowledge the existence
of taiwan and
they're not even trying to hide it this
clip have show i've showed it to you
several times
but it's still bone chillingly scary
here would the who
consider taiwan's membership
hello
okay let me let me repeat the question
no that's okay
let's move to another one then right
because because i'm
i'm actually curious on talking about
taiwan as well on taiwan's case
unbelievable and and
you know that interview is so polite
asians are often so political oh wait
wait let me repeat that question no no
let's move on no no but how do you not
know you want
how do you know you not want this
question if you're not here question
let me make you hear a question no that
sounds italian help you
yeah i don't know it's a good italian
accent here's the thing you guys are
keeping
not keeping in mind you can actually
stream disney in the re-education
uyghur camps and that's one that's
that's something you don't that's a
benefit
that's how they got to the hundred plus
million subscribers yeah they're
counting all over in the
million or so years in concentration
camps which you never hear about by the
way
i mean that's a lot of critical i don't
know you started to hear about it about
a year and a half or two years after we
were like sounding the alarm like hey
guys you remember rwanda and everybody
thought oh my gosh this is this is
terrible this is happening we're
actually complicit
you're complicit in china now yeah
they've known for a very long time but
you know what they
at least at least they have disney plus
so in between bowing to mecca five times
a day they can check in with mandalorian
and
oh no no so gina carano is a threat but
the uyghurs nobody brings that up i
guess
i guess disney i've been bringing it up
since 2009 because i visited guantanamo
bay and i saw the uyghur prison and they
had an oceanside view
oh did they and xboxes well they make
you watch moulin as torture so
the new version but did nato interview
any of the uyghurs when they were
talking about china not being a threat
i don't think so they were too busy
watching mulan and we'll make
a man out of you well listen i don't
know
we can do that now we have the
technology you can't have the king and i
okay hey by the way comment what your
thoughts are was what should we be doing
about
china do you think that china this is
just comment that's the best thing you
can do here on youtube
why are we talking about russia and no
one's discussing china i know i don't
understand
he's to india why did angela just walk
in do we know what's going to
she uh helping with something in the
show no there's something going wrong
she wanted to hang out
oh okay all right never mind all right
uh and this is just my final point on
this they're trying to act like canceled
culture exists on both sides
so nope nope listen people say oh oh
republican you don't want canceled
culture when you're
when you're trying to remove someone for
a death threat on twitter
right we're talking about following the
law overwhelmingly
cancel culture banning people for
unpopular opinions comes from the left
and it just so happens they control
facebook twitter youtube google apple
amazon and now they're banning books
great good
progress we'll come along i'll tell you
what let's meet in the middle a little
bit
uh sarah silverman and just come out
just once
protest the banning of books you do that
we'll give you a little bit of grace
all right uh george floyd we'll move on
to this here his toxicology report
people may not know this but now it's
been it'll be admitted as evidence uh
revealed fatal levels of fentanyl
in his system that causes lungs to fill
with fluid uh
as well as methamphetamine covid and
over the week in the city of minneapolis
paid george floyd the family 27 million
dollars
in a wrongful death settlement
chasing the dragon if it's dirty it's
not heroin it's chinese fentanyl
and chinese fentanyl is deadlier
thank you pj the crack muppet but we
gotta and more
awesome no no no no no no no no pj the
crap get rid of pj the correct mop but i
don't want him here i don't want him
no we have kids who watch this no no get
him get rid of him get rid of him get
rid of him
we don't want you to mark this as chill
is child friendly
um wow can't believe mixing fat
it's a problem he needs to get his life
together it cuts through though it keeps
you kind of even
keeled so fentanyl covid19 in his system
here's just what before we move on to
this
why aren't we being consistent fentanyl
methamphetamine also thc stuff like that
um remember the florida guy who died in
a motorcycle crash
he was listed as a cove 19 death why
isn't george floyd being listed as a cop
of 19 death when we say oh it's derek
chauvin
which again the report doesn't show that
he was killed by you know some
by the pressure to his neck horrible
police training we know that drugs
obviously would have
would have interfered right now with
coca-19 there would have been some
co-morbidities i would imagine yeah but
kovid19 and he was saying i can't
breathe i can't breathe let me ask you
this
if you go to a hospital and you say i
can't breathe
i feel like i can't breathe and then
they test you positive or covet and you
die you think they're gonna list you as
a covet death
of course they listen to the guy who
crashed his motorcycle drunk off his ass
as a cop at death and a guy in michigan
who tried to blow his head off with a
shotgun as a covid death
but now with george floyd want to
believe the only contributing factor
was a neon on he did kneel on his neck
for eight
minutes yeah it doesn't help no of
course not but stephen
yeah it's a terrible thing hold on
something really quick
so george floyd had covered 19. yes
you said it but i have not heard that
before yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you had coco 19. the
tax college report says
it shows that cover 19. yeah but if you
want me to lean on i can kneel on
anybody's neck here we'll see how well
that goes for you i guarantee you
we're not going to die so yeah that's
the thing i don't know you think do you
think that's what killed him
i do think that's what killed him okay i
always think though if you're gonna
kneel on somebody's neck for eight
minutes that's that's shitty police
oh no no no i think it's absolutely
correct there isn't a truck there isn't
a cop in this country that agrees with
that but
except for the training pamphlet that
they handed out that's how they train
these police officers
to to kneel on yes yes i mean
i know they train them you can we can
probably bring it up have them bring it
up from the control room that's the
problem is they teach these police
officers
to kneel on the back of the neck and if
you watch it he has one knee on the
ground so all of his weight isn't on a
george foreign
we don't know right hold on brian two
things can be true at the same time
right yeah he would have died of
fentanyl and this is
that work right both things can be true
it doesn't mean
that the officer and we don't know yet
caused his death because i think the
coroner's report comes out and says well
his lungs filled up with fluid that
didn't have anything to do with the knee
on the neck
right and i'm not i'm not saying
anything okay and i
and i still think that if you're gonna
kneel on somebody's neck for eight
minutes you're going to pay a price for
it and probably
no i agree i understand i i get the
frustration with that but you have to be
able to separate out what actually
happened and this is
it's not saying that this is what you do
this is what the left cannot and refuses
to do they they
focus so much on one thing that they
don't look at any of the other evidence
well they also listen they also have you
look at the entire george floyd arrest
tape i
i have so we showed it here in the like
the thing is they were being very very
nice with them for very long they were
but
they were saying hey hey man yeah i'm
not gonna leave you by yourself look
look i'll open a window
man i can't breathe i can't my mom just
died his mom just died he's acting very
reaching yeah exactly the guy said put
your hands on the steering wheel put
your hands on the steering wheel he
didn't i said look look man i'm going to
stay with you i'm going to stay with you
i'm going to open the window and you get
in the car
i can't breathe i can't breathe and then
it went to use the police
training this isn't the police manual
that's why it's horrible guys that guy
look you still have you had four dudes
there
there's got to be a better way to yeah
to restrain somebody of course
yeah you don't charge the guy you don't
charge the guy with murder that can be
true at the same time though that's what
i'm saying yes there is there was a
better way they should have done it
differently but
did they cause george floyd to die
that's the question that we have to get
to
also nobody speak ill of our lord and
savior
george floyd christ uh marvin hagel
we're gonna go on to the george floyd
and the riots that it's
again like you're saying both things can
be true unfortunately the entire
what you're talking about that's been
the entire narrative right and that's
what justifies riots
in damages 900 officer casualties over
19 deaths because no one knows that this
guy had coveted complications lung
problems
and fentanyl at lethal doses in his
system something that i just want to
mention marvin hagler one of my favorite
boxers of all time
uh died at 66 years of age this weekend
after being hospitalized in the icu now
this is something that a lot of people
don't know
all if you run a search on this and i
cannot confirm or deny it okay
but all the articles will say it's fake
news people saying that he died from
complications with the coveted vaccine
but here's where that comes from
tommy hearns and everyone knows right
the famous the best first round ever in
the history of boxing my dad was there
in the arena oh wow
um he uh was friends with with uh i was
about to say joe louis he was friends
with marvin hagler for the rest of his
life
and he tweeted the day before marvin
hagler died he tweeted hey
he'll probably be all right but my best
my buddy marvin hagler
suffering from side effects from the
covered vaccine send prayers
and positive energy his way this was
before
he died so you can speculate as to
whether tommy hearns got bad information
but again
they were close for the rest of their
life they became colleagues they were
they had just they had the most
mind-blowing fights if people out there
who are young
generation z millennials go just watch
hagler hearn so this is where it comes
from
you can't say it's fake if it comes from
someone's verified account who knew
hagler very well and by the way
there's been no other information to
corroborate or deny it so
just want to make that really clear as
to why some folks are confused
also here's here's the police procedure
uh
showing like the kneeling on the neck
yeah so wow that's what they show that's
what i'm saying so in other words we
can't
we can't hang a guy lynch a guy if he's
doing what he was trained to do
won't this all come out in court the
good thing about due process
is we get to have this conversation yeah
like one of the cool things is that this
is a this
is that now we know he had that much
fentanyl and all of us go
we've been hold on we've known that yeah
yeah we've done it for a long time but
everybody has to now take all those
things into account that's kind of what
i love about due process kind of
the problem is now you have you have
jurists who are going to be afraid
even if they see the truth because they
know that their lives are going to be in
danger that's the problem of public
opinion
taking place before the actual trial
which brings us to
look um even as of the family now 27
million dollars
which to me that's you know significant
um chauvinism is on trial now for
manslaughter
second and third degree murder regularly
they originally they wanted to get first
degree murder so i don't know how that
works legally
we'll have my half-assing lawyer on to
talk about how they plea down um
but what's been going the riots are
still going on by the way so 27
no justice no peace okay here's 27
million and right now we're gonna have a
trial a jury of their peers
second third degree murder manslaughter
right which could result in consecutive
sentences
no no no we're gonna we go go burn the
walgreens
okay i don't know if that's necessarily
bringing justice to anybody but you do
you
keep it real so let's go here we have
minnesota friday night there was a
drive-by
shooting in the george floyd autonomous
zone it's like chas only more violent
this is what happened there was a
shooting in the autonomous zone
it's a steve you're such an agitator
this is what it is
here's what happens this isn't the
minnesota autonomous zone guy got shot
wouldn't let the cops in and so what
happened is they carried
this person who was shot they carried
him out to the hospital the police
couldn't get to him
and this person died and i'm sure they
just did a tremendous job of stabilizing
that victim's spine
um and so uh by the time the cops
arrived the victim
had been brought died here's a here's a
clip
the cops can't get in
wow look this is in minnesota where they
don't allow cops in that area
yeah yeah wow that's helpful to those
poor neighborhoods
yeah ah who cares about the
neighborhoods those people got something
to say i have a question
yeah tell me if i'm right about this
stat probably not i believe in 2019 or
2020
policing has gotten so good that into in
of the
10 million plus arrests only nine
unarmed
black men were actually shot is this
true i think it's 2018.
i think it was eight or nine and then
there were 19 white people i mean
that's if you look at i'll take those
odds if i'm playing the lottery
any circle if you if you had a test and
it was 10 million questions
and you only got nine or you know what
50 or a hundred wrong yeah that's
that's well that's not is that an a it
depends if what i got wrong came from a
training pamphlet
well that's not the problem that they
point out they point out any black
person
meaning a person with a gun who happens
to be black who is aiming it at an
officer firing if that officer shoots
back
this i i'm just saying that policing has
gotten better
as a result of the pressures from 2015
onward we know that
no no it was always it was always pretty
good yeah it was always even before
2015. it was always a lie that's a thing
that's a hell of an accomplishment
if it's just nine people i'm not saying
there isn't police
no none of us listen we're all
christians here so we believe that
everybody is flawed however you can't
just see people through
the lens of race and cops because then
oh wait a second there are more
there's a higher percentage of cops who
are black than the actual percentage of
black people in the population
oh what do we do there more black people
right now in the united states of
america
believe in at least as much of a police
presence as there is or more
i wonder why maybe because of what you
just saw in minneapolis i'm sure the
woman who lost her son
probably wasn't too fond of the fact
that some white antifa
and unfortunately i hate to say this but
black people who go along with them
because they think their allies shielded
the police from saving her son's life
and the paramedics i'm sure that black
mom's not thrilled with it the hits keep
on coming
in louisville kentucky protesters
intimidated young girls going to a
because this is privilege this is
systemic oppression when i think
systemic oppression
i think we need to send a gaggle
of uh uh protesters to stop girls from
going to a cheerleading
you're comparing them to geese when you
say they're beautiful you're beautiful
canadian
spoke to a protest organizer who stands
by what happened
and a parent who says children should
not have been involved
[Music]
comments made as cheerleaders headed
into a competition at the kentucky
international convention center saturday
have parents upset so now we go to
portland where the hits keep on coming
um you're inflexible and uh hours after
the only had a barricade in portland
around the courthouse
hours after it came down hours hours
sir after it came down uh antifa
and black lives matter activists set the
federal courthouse on fire
while people were inside that's like the
church in the patriot here's a clip
[Music]
not to mention of course you remember in
los angeles the molotov cocktails
being thrown at the drive-through
that's a music video and wendy's is not
healthy food so no no it doesn't know
i'm just saying that's your problem
they don't use grass-fed burgers and in
my opinion that's that's about they
don't use the beyond
meat that's murder that is murder and
you know what something else if you
watch a lot of these protests you see
them you see guys with tactical vests
and firearms right and by the way i have
no problem with that i don't have a
i have a problem mainly with the burning
of buildings burning in the federal
courthouse
destroying neighborhoods that harm black
families and white families alike
but i don't have a problem with someone
exercising their second amendment right
but the argument against cal written
house is
why would someone be going down to these
protests
with a firearm you know well look i saw
dozens of people across the country you
can google it yourself you can run a
youtube search if the search still
allows you to find it
of them walking around with ar-15s and
tactical vests hey why don't we use that
argument there
why are they going down to black lives
matter pro why are they going
well look and i think it's actually
legitimate hold on a second i don't so
much have a problem with you wearing a
tactical vest and carrying an ar15
as i do with you carrying said tactical
vest and ar-15
on the way to burning down the
courthouse with people inside of it
that's my primary equipment yeah yeah
and do you think they were complaining
about the guy who was trying to actually
shoot kyle rittenhouse who ended up
shooting him in the bicep that guy had
i think a gun do you mean the serial
pedophile yeah the criminal that
actually had a weapon as well that they
haven't said one word about
him no he had a gun in his hand and he
was
almost about to point it out and they
were trying to take out right now his
gun yeah yeah and the guy had raped
children
he had literally oh yeah one of the guys
shot had raped children
convicted not put his hand on his back
and said something inappropriate
raped young children really yeah these
are the best of the best that's what i
call her right just kill
that's what you want to make that's what
i call a righteous kill yeah
figuratively
figuratively yeah the other guy just hit
him over the head with a skateboard with
the truck
right up right on the back right on his
head yeah he kind of died
yeah he almost he had sort of jumped in
the air and tried to
get his i kind of want to crowdsource
this so everyone out there comment
where do you live out there tell me the
general uh area of where you live
and what have you seen this last weekend
because the riots have been picking up
uh again
now here's what's interesting again when
we're talking about canceled culture
earlier we're talking about george floyd
and we're talking about the double
standard
the media these rights have been going
on all weekend yeah right we just
courthouse burned down with people
inside yeah the media is still talking
about the january 6th
capital riot right that's what they
still are focusing on which lasted for
three hours
lasted for three hours this is uh uh or
is this so there's a montage i guess
sorry
they're still talking about the capital
riot here you go and tonight we were
stunned when we learned that the justice
department says it expects to arrest at
least
100 more people in connection with the
capital attack on january 6th
more than 300 people have already been
charged authorities are
narrowing in on two far-right extremist
groups the oath keepers and the proud
boys as they investigate what happened
on january
6th they show um for the oath keepers
for example that fat guy's not making it
up that wall no
preparing for january 6 very much as if
they were heading for
rotting through the capital looking for
lawmakers
the washington post reports that the
extremists were minutes
away from reaching vice president mike
pence sacrament
so it was three hours and 30 million
dollars a day and by the way
horrible anyone who committed an act of
violence now the one person
shot was shot by capitol police and i'm
not saying unjustifiably so right we
don't have the information we don't know
what happened with the other five deaths
because most of them seem to have
happened several days later from natural
causes according to their families
and their own texts however um
something a lot of people don't know so
this happened once right and keep in
mind
when they say 93 of black lives matter
uh protests are peaceful well first off
that's [ __ ]
second there were hundreds of thousands
of people at the capitol you're talking
about a group of
dozens of people who went rogue and
obviously people should be held
accountable for their actions
but they have more guards not only more
guards than at the border right now they
not only have more troops than at the
border they didn't have any troops it's
not a disaster at the border by the way
they're sending fema which is not a
disaster
no organization no they're sending fema
it's just like it's fun it's just oh
it's just think of it like a clown in a
hazmat suit
so they have not only at the state
capitol it went on for three hours right
total no other legitimate threats since
then it was something that happened
spontaneously wasn't a pre-planned
molotov cocktailing
uh they have more troops not only than
at the border they have more troops
at the capitol than in afghanistan and
iraq
combined yeah that's because that's
because
liberals love guns as long as they're in
the hands of the state
yes and and you know military-grade
weapons are fine in the hands of the
state
but then we need it but then was the
statement on our side yes and by the way
we have a problem with the
militarization of police okay well what
do i do if i have an intruder
uh you don't need a you don't need 20
rounds call the police
which ones the racist police whose uh
precinct we bombed
i think that we're a little murky on the
connect the dots on the back of the
children's menu here
yeah well and just out of curiosity i
mean we've republicans or conservative
groups have had
several dozens of protests i'm trying to
think back to the last time a
conservative group got together to
protest and it turned violent
yeah no you can this is the thing they
say look at this is one time
one time right and these people were
rogue actors you did have scientific
people in there but i'm not saying they
were all
believe me i'm not going with that
narrative no no every single tea party
yeah nothing nothing nothing as a matter
of fact they left the place cleaner
than they found what they did were the
mission second amendment yeah
and we were there too where we did it
with it nothing right
nothing every major protest
black lives matter every single major
city
that has had a protest has had millions
in damages
and usually a death or two certainly
officer casualties or serious injuries
every single major city 93
people so let's compare the capital
riots to with these rights the numbers
are
minimum 2 billion dollars in damages
right minimum
900 officer casualties minimum 19 lives
lost over the riots just over the summer
we have no idea
what's going to happen right now what do
you think's going to happen when they
don't find this guy guilty of murder
which is very likely considering the
evidence at hand what do you think is
going to happen why do you think there's
an ammo shortage
and here's something else funny portland
mayor ted wheeler i always get portland
and seattle mixed up because you know
they're both they're both just
same sub city yeah white gate really
just just just white people with bad
tattoos and sensible shoes
and speak for black people
outraged for black people elbowing black
people out of the way
they are to black people with a
non-alcoholic at an a.a meeting like
just glad to be here yeah and it's
literally an event
la la the protests were an event i swear
to god for white people they were like
there's a protest
i'll bring the sun block let's do this
it was unbelievable
do you think you got the bose speaker do
you think it's do you think i do you
think it's pass a to bring back my
rodney king sign do you have to do a new
one i don't know
where are the rhinestones let's go tag
that bodega in a neighborhood i'd never
drive through much less to live in
right get out of here so portland mayor
ted wheeler which is just such a it's
just such a white name
yeah ted wheeler ted wheeler hey hey
i'm ted wheeler ted wheeler he's on your
side
ted there's been injustice against
blacks looks like it's time to call in
the wheel
let's call ted damn it ted
you're rogue ted you're a loose cannon
i'll have your desk on my badge and my
badge on your desk and your gun
damn it i do things my way damn that ted
these blacks have been kept down far too
long but ted wheeler does a ted
wheeler's way
and he just goes out and they're like oh
man i see a nice car
well yeah now it's getting jacked oh but
i'm one of you oh good
you can be one of us riding the bus
[ __ ] so
portland mayor ted wheeler just
requested two million dollars to fund
quote proactive policing to combat the
huge rise
in gun violence what a surprise i mean
um
are we do they really think that we're
not going to see what's happening by
just
like when they say proact we want some
more money we're defunding the police
yeah one's like i think that's pretty
stupid
and then they go oh looks like it was
pretty stupid i know we need more money
but we'll just say
we need it for proactive policing like
you'd sneak it in on us like we wouldn't
know
that your screw-up led to a rise in
crime and now you know that you need the
cops yeah they're looking around going
oh man my policies really suck but not
apologizing for any of it and saying oh
we just decided this random spike in
crime i mean
we didn't know that we need two million
dollars for preemptive
constabling i have a i have a theory
true
every time i hear and i'm not talking
about black people here i'm just talking
about when i when i hear
white wokers who are talking about
defunding the police and i've done a
study i usually just look at them
they almost always look like people that
have never done any kind of a sport
never been punched in the face
and that's significant because i think
you have to have some
idea of what real violence feels like
yeah you know what i mean it just
it just makes you a little more afraid
yeah i feel like there should be a
realization where they should be hitting
the face with a snare drum
maybe but there's also a theory that
liberals
tend to like sort of the liberal mindset
tends to think that when you take all
restraints off a human being
they flourish and a conservative mindset
is that we're flawed people
and if you don't have some rules people
do crazy stuff
right so very easy you know it depends
on your philosophy on what hormones
is let's forget about investigating
these rioters let's have preemptive
constabling
and let's make sure that black lives
matter is uh yet again nominated for a
nobel peace prize
just so i'm washing my ass what was that
what
what the what's that uh token hour no it
was it was nothing
what's happening are you using are you
using the the work computer again
very fast and i just got my nails done
and they were so
pointy this is on your computer
wow do you know that i stabbed my
[ __ ] oh by the way
yeah nominated for a grammy i can't tell
the difference between cardi b
and uh megan the uh megan the horse
megan the stallion sir
and you know what does she know what a
stallion is does she know that a
stallion is a male
horse it's a male or they got bigger
shouldn't she be megan or megan the
mayor
i would i think so yeah megan the mayor
that looks like a stallion that could be
a little more anatomical although are we
talking about the difference between
male and
female because wet ass [ __ ] tends to be
that's a little offensive to people who
literally
unless i'm like you know no no you're
wrong you've made an assumption yeah wet
ass
um because we can't say it on youtube
but they can be nominated
which is if you haven't uh if you
haven't uh it could be weeping
uh a weeping uh
we've all had an open poison ivy uh uh
hit your head your your front hole is
weeping
it is me that sounds like euphemism i
hope that you use expressvpn by the way
well
i don't want anyone okay and they're a
wonderful sponsor to the show if you out
there
are looking up megan the stallion cardi
b go to uh you should use expressvpn
expressvpn.com
crowder you get three months free um
really just stop handing over while
we're talking about all this your data
to big tech and government who i
well i repeat myself um we use
expressvpn when we have found the uh
youtube algorithms there with tulsi
just keep yourself protected use it if
you're not using a vpn today
you're an idiot and you shouldn't be
watching the show okay
turn it off right now do it listen we
use it we only have sponsors that we
actually use i can i
cannot tell you how many supplement
companies have come to like run spots on
the show
and about 90 of them i just say oh okay
are you
uh gmp and nsf certified and then i
never hear from them again
i was like look i'm going to be selling
my i'm not going to be selling my
audience steroids with some little pixie
dust
botanical premium privatized proprietary
blend
where you're putting in powdered sugar
and a little bit of rhubarb
but stephen it has the acai berry in it
ah yes well the problem with acai is
that it comes from brazil and i don't
trust them so
that's the problem presumably there's
too many brazilians yeah i don't mean
a race i'm in the country um
right now hey why are you talking do you
want to fudge hey
i used to be a fan you show my club but
now
i don't know okay i'm not
i don't want to be your friend you could
take that's a good
line of defense there that's good
chinese accents yes very good
i think i was going for korean i just
feel like he was being stereotypically
chinese right there yeah yeah i'm sorry
keep seeing look at my tits and my
sweater keep get the camera off me
forget it
let me see it i got it i'm throwing this
sweater away don't
don't don't dry your sweater kids that's
that's the theme of this show that's the
theme of the show also don't shop at gap
kids
so i'm sorry gymboree i know i
i identify as a man but i'm a kid uh
this is while we're talking about who's
looking out for you so we were talking
about china
canceled culture because now they're
going uh who's bill maher saying we need
to do something about china well you
know what someone was kind of looking
out for us talking about china donald
trump republicans this show for a very
long time
um and now they're talking who's looking
out for you when it comes to guns
gun safety this is something that re
that to me
okay look i want i'm gonna i'm gonna go
a question to you guys but let me you're
about to hear this and i wanna
hear any argument and maybe you can
provide one for the other side of this
there are some times where i understand
why they believe this because you know
they think abortion up until
nine months and including after birth
because they're just selfish [ __ ]
right now so i understand where they're
coming from this is one i don't
under and i don't actually know that's
because yes there but there's some
policies like they want a progressive
tax rate
okay student loan i understand where
they're coming from they don't ask the
question why is college so expensive we
just want to buy
votes this is one where they're talking
about gun control and that's the next
big push and we'll be focusing on it
um thursday 17 democrats voted against
a republican republican representative i
want to make sure i get
ben klein he had a motion to recommit um
bill hr eight okay so what he is uh
looking to have added to recommit this
bill
is this is something it would seem that
it should be bipartisan
four basically when people when illegal
immigrants try to purchase a firearm
illegally that it alerts that the atf
alerts ice
basically okay it's just putting out the
butterfly net for them felons
seems like we should all be on board if
we're talking about background checks
and limiting magazine capacity let's
just make sure
that the ms-13 not the best of the
brightest aren't purchasing
firearms in this country illegally here
is uh
the proposed recommitment in his own
words
thank you mr speaker enough is enough
which is why i rise in strong opposition
to hr8 and to offer a motion to recommit
the bill
this bill is nothing more than a
coordinated effort by the authoritarian
left
to strip away the constitutional rights
guaranteed to americans by the second
amendment
instead of criminalizing the innocent
actions of law-abiding gun owners
american citizens we should be focused
on stopping real crime in our local
communities
and enforcing the laws that are already
on the books one way
we can do that is by ensuring that ice
is notified
when unlawful aliens attempt to purchase
a firearm illegally
i i like him but i don't like that he's
wearing a mask i prefer if he'd have
gone rand paul or rand paul
they're like motion to make a
representative paul where's mask i don't
care
i'm not going to i don't
know i'm going to eat my cookies here on
the floor no no i hope i don't get
crumbs all over your mouth
that's rand paul i love him they got to
change out the mic every time
every time so look here's the thing
these 17 democrats they're the only 17
remaining i believe of 19 i don't know
if i have that right but i know that
these 17
voted uh for the same motion back in
2018.
and i got a bunch of crap from aoc look
this is something so let me let me get
this straight
we're talking about hr 127 um sheila
jackson lee we did a whole segment on
her
crazy [ __ ] right who's proposing this
crazy gun control law where they want to
limit your limit magazine basically turn
the rest of the country into california
make it nearly impossible to purchase
firearms so that you can protect
yourselves
indefinite wait times you can go back
and watch our whole segment on it so
while they
tell you where your guns are yeah you
have to be able to you have to actually
publicly state where you keep your guns
in your house yeah next to my porn
what who said that so they know exactly
where to molotov cocktail the building
yeah or robbie it's just so so they want
to take away the right
of sovereign american citizens who were
born here who follow the law
their god-given right your god-given
right to self-preservation
but they don't want when illegal
immigrants would be
purchasing the same said firearms only
it's
illegal because they're here illegally
they don't want to
actually track those people so they want
to make sure that we can track you
you me not only how many firearms we
have not only tracking how many rounds
we have in some places like california
where it is in your house on a national
registry but oppose
simply alerting the organization in
charge of illegal immigration
why why because illegal immigration
results in crime
and black markets they oppose that
because
they need to purchase a voting base so
if someone out there if someone out
there can find
any argument please liberals anyone who
watches i don't know stelter any of
these progressive shows there really
aren't many on youtube anymore that are
very successful
but the point anyone out there who can
make the argument
i just make the argument as to why we
shouldn't just be catching illegal
immigrants especially
by the way if they're an illegal
immigrant and they're dumb enough to
fill out a background check
look they're not going to be your next
software engineers send them in their
teardrop
tattoo back to honduras i think if
you're that
that into decriminalizing the border you
should be
you should be forced to take in a family
that you're fighting so hard for maybe
just give them a key to your front door
or take
the front door off your house if you
don't believe in any kind of borders
i think borders are reasonable i don't
want kids in cages etc
but if you really believe that put your
money where your mouth is
if you're one of these democrats that's
voting for that then then
how about making a room in your house
for one of the just one of those
families yeah
or just one person how about that or
have any of them done that here's the
other comparison right what is this buy
one get one free on crime like you get
to commit two crimes before we actually
prosecute you have to go to a third
crime okay so here's the thing i'll
break into your house and i'll steal
your money that's two crimes
you can't do it breaking and entering
and then theft but you can't prosecute
me
because i haven't committed that third
crime and then by the way depending on
where you are in a sanctuary city you
can fill up our prisons and democrats
are still
against deporting violent felons in our
prisons look this is the issue and i've
talked about this before when it comes
to abortion okay
let me let me let me really clarify it
too when it comes to illegal immigration
with abortion
sometimes christians or specifically
catholics will get mad at me because
they think i'm conceding ground
where i support abortion in cases of
rape and incest no
what i'm doing is when someone says well
what about rape and incest with abortion
i respond with okay if we allow
abortion let's say we allow it for rape
and incest okay
you won't hear any argument from me
would you then be okay with banning all
the ones that will no well then don't
bring up rape and incest that's not what
you care about same thing where they say
what about children what about dreamers
okay look
how about this okay if we were to say
that every single child whose parents
who who were used by their parents is
basically an anchor baby so that they
could remain here illegally and
definitely
that we'll give them a pass would you be
okay
with deporting already convicted
violent felons who are illegal
immigrants overcrowding our prison
systems
or at least alerting ice when illegal
immigrants try to purchase an illegal
firearm no then don't tell me it's about
children
you don't care don't get bogged down on
that quagmire because it's not about
kids
just like abortion is not about rape and
incest don't let them get you off track
the left today
believes that someone should be able to
walk across
the border that doesn't exist that isn't
protected
not necessarily have to pay taxes not be
on the books come into this country
claim citizenship
when and if they want to or if they
don't still receive all the societal
benefits whether it's welfare ebt
health care right no way to track them
and they believe that they should be
able to purchase a firearm which you
should never be allowed to purchase
not be alerted to the authorities and
commit crimes
and remain here in our prison system
which by the way is compared uh
to honduras el salvador salvadorian or
mexican prisons an absolute resort
okay it's like club med with a boyfriend
in your room well they want to talk
about white privilege it sounds like
there's illegal immigrant privilege
yes in a lot of these cities it's like
that's the best thing to be we're not
gonna we're not gonna deport you if you
know convicted of a crime we're not
gonna actually
you know make it a crime to do really
anything that's a crime for everybody
else to buy a gun illegally is a
crime it's the second crime to being an
illegal immigrant buying a gun illegally
and then we're gonna put you up not to
mention care of you taxes
do you know how much you know how much
of a luxury that is everyone we're
approaching tax season
how much of a luxury it would be for my
accountant to be like
uh all right hey you've got to pay your
taxes uh now by april and you go
no not so much
that's great nah i don't think so
maybe a little bit no i don't feel like
paying taxes
sounds fine by me that's the democratic
party of today all right we have to get
going here pretty soon
brian callum is going to be where uh uh
huntsville alabama yeah
alabama stand up live march 25 26 27
and tomorrow is our one year anniversary
mega party 15 days to flatten the curve
um we're gonna go here take your chats
uh on mug club loudspear.com slash mug
club and see if we can get my pooch joe
lewis
to do his impression of a fire fi fire
hydrant a fire engine
a fire truck here in the studio because
it's a slow news day and um
and people like dogs so uh thank you for
youtube i appreciate you having we're
still up yeah
good well thank you so much look thank
you for doing the bare minimum but still
piss off lou